Mother's Day is this Sunday and Andy I
was curious you doing anything special
for your mom uh well I mean to be honest
my mom and I just aren't really that
close she lives in the Midwest with my
sister and but she doesn't really like
getting on the phone so I'll probably
just call and leave a message like I do
every year wow I don't I don't know what
to say Andy but at least you're making
an effort well yeah I mean it's it's
just where we are yeah
excuse me mr. O'Brien Oh XR a camera
operator Rick what's problem Rick I
don't mean to butt in but I think Andy
should do a little more than just call
his mom especially if there's friction
there gosh Rick thanks for the advice
but why don't you back off I mean what
do you think you're my mom
how do I tell them the truth after all
these years after all the lies after all
the gender reassignment surgery I am
your mother Andy this job to be close to
you
well check check it out Rick's really
staring at you Andy yeah I know it's
weird stop staring at me Rick
you don't fool me for a second Rick I
know you're really my mom I've known for
the last seven years but I'm not gonna
give you the satisfaction of telling you
not after the way you raised me you and
I have nothing in common mom we never
did and we never will Andy Andy Andy you
might want to take it easy with the
alcohol back off who are you my dad
Oh God he's on to me I am your father
man why did I have kids so young and why
do I tell people I'm 53 when I'm really
78 I'm through with this [ __ ] I'm
gonna tell Andi I'm his dad
and I love him hey Andi
yeah Thomas Middleditch is coming up you
excited yeah I love Thomas Middleditch
me too happy Mother's Day everybody
[Applause]
you
you